if uh he becomes Trump becomes a prop  Republican nominee or descendants become  Republican nominee do you think both of  them have a chance of winning the whole  thing at this early stage I would say  somebody other than Trump has a better  shot at winning the whole thing  because Democrats and independents just  I see a very difficult Road getting them  to support Donald Trump and one of the  biggest factors in the upcoming primary  is going to be if all the polls start to  show let's just say to santis DeSantis  is beating Biden scientist is beating  Harris by five points and Trump is only  beating them by one  that is going to be a shocking message  to Republican primary voters who say I'm  not taking a chance I do not want  somebody who could lose this thing